this is a typical American Suburban
street it's wide the houses are very far
apart and look mostly the same
there is barely anything on the world
manicured Lawns post boxes a few trees
or bushes and the occasion of fire
hydrant
now compare this to a Suburban Leipzig
Germany what differences do you notice
first off there is stuff around you the
streetscape is very diverse and mentally
engaging in comparison the American
suburb looks like a desolate Urban
Wasteland
also in the European suburb the street
is narrow there is a 30 kilometers per
hour speed limit and the buildings are
close together do notice the tram tracks
in this suburb you can lift car free if
you want to go to the center you can
either take the tram or ride your bike
for 20 minutes on dedicated bike Lanes
or take yes Bond because there's also a
train station
in the American suburb you have no
option but to drive head out onto the
busy Strode a horrifying mix of street
and Road onto the jammed Highway and
after an hour you'll be in the center
searching for a parking spot
how about going to a restaurant in the
European suburb there are dozens of
different unique local restaurants
reachable and food by bike or public
transit in the American suburb you're an
hour walk away from a chain restaurant
next day busy Strode if you want to eat
you gotta get in your car
what if you have children in this
European suburb there are three schools
close by kids can walk or bike there on
their own and learn to be independent
early on in the American suburb a child
could get to school after 35 minutes of
walking mostly along a busy arterial
Road also having to cross a six Lanes
Road somehow I mean there's no crosswalk
so kids have to be driven to schools
every day by Mommy and Daddy
foreign
goes for sports over here kids can take
a 10 minute walk to the nearest sports
field or a three minute bike ride on
calm Safe Streets on their own in the US
it's a 40-minute March through a major
Street partially along a major Transit
artery gotta get in the SUV and let
Mommy drive you to practice this is
where the term soccer mom originates
from by the way people lament today's
children for being overly dependent on
their parents but in such neighborhoods
children don't have a choice but to be
dependent otherwise they cannot go
anywhere they are stuck at home in
contrast in European suburbs kids can be
let out safely to move around on their
own to go to places they want to without
the need for the mummy and daddy taxi
service
do note that yellow residential building
on the left that is a mid-rise European
suburbs tend to be a mixture of those
and single or multi-family homes like on
this street
zoning in U.S suburbs only allows for
single-family homes and they are usually
placed very far apart leading to low
density and long distances this makes
public transportation non-viable over
here in Europe hundreds of people live
within walking distance of this tram
stop in the U.S if you put a trim stop
here you would have a few dozen people
living within walking distance meaning
even if you build public transit here
almost nobody would take it because no
matter how you build it people would be
too far away from it if you're half an
hour away on food from the nearest tram
stop you'll take your car instead and
people do so giant highways had to be
built rammed right into the city usually
demolishing non-white neighborhoods in
the process the end result was mass
motorization all across America constant
traffic jams noise and pollution but not
for the suburbanites it was the urban
dwellers particularly those who were
poor who had to live near higher traffic
areas in cheap low quality housing the
suburbs also became a growth Ponzi
scheme where income from the suburbs
couldn't cover a future infrastructure
overhauls so the city had to expand and
sell new properties constantly to get
enough money to maintain what they
already have not just bikes due a great
video about this link in the description
the suburbs and core Centric development
were useful political tools in the 1950s
to enforce a Christian conservative
white nationalist hierarchy within
American society where white men are on
top women are at home fully dependent on
their husbands and where all resources
are channeled towards the white middle
and upper class in the form of billions
in state subsidies and the rest of
society poor people non-whites were left
to fend for themselves in decaying Urban
centers sucked dry financially by the
parasitic suburbs around them
core-centric planning became a weapon of
choice for conservatives in order to
maintain the unequal status score and
this phenomenon isn't unique to America
in Europe as our cities transition away
from Cars the opponents of this change
are almost always conservatives while
the incumbent Paris mayor campaigned on
eliminating 50 000 parking spaces her
conservative opponent who looks frankly
diabolical even by French standards
wanted to Halt decongestion measures in
Prague a city overrun by cars
conservatives keep screaming about these
cyclo fascists ruining the city after a
shadow is painted somewhere meanwhile
conservative District Mayors are busy
turning sidewalks into parking lots in
Madrid the conservative City leadership
canceled the ultra low emission zones
leading to local protests to bring them
back in Budapest we have orban's
far-right conservatives screaming about
how there is a Witch Hunt against
drivers by the new center left mayor and
complaining how an inner city Budapest
it's almost faster to walk now than to
drive even in Germany Bavarian
conservatives are dumping money into
highways while letting the rail network
fall into this repair as a rule of thumb
in every city with decongestion measures
you'll also find conservatives screaming
about the war on cars the symbol of
hierarchy in transportation where the
affluent Suburban minority gets to
occupy 80 of public space inside cities
compared to the more egalitarian space
use of public transit and bicycles God
forbid you have to get out of your giant
SUV of death and get on a trend with the
peasants of course upholding the
conservative hierarchy isn't why suburbs
are built today in the US it's mostly
just a necessary continuation of the
Ponzi scheme that began with the first
suburbs also it's due to faulty zoning
codes not allowing for midwives
developments that would actually make
more money for the city increased
density and make public transit viable
in Europe our suburbs are mixed with
both mid Rises single and multi-family
homes they're an organic part of the
city and contribute fairly to the local
budget there is also subsidized
affordable public transit all in all
it's more egalitarian and if the U.S
situation sounds depressing in contrast
as an American there are things you can
do to potentially help change things if
there is a local Transit Fighters Union
go join it look if there are any
initiatives on the ballot for traffic
calming bike Lanes Etc show up to your
local Town Hall meetings and advocate
for zoning reform ending parking
minimums and so on if you're persistent
enough your ideas will be heard and you
can help push America back towards
sensible Fair more egalitarian urban
planning one neighborhood at a time
that's what I would do if I were you
thank you for watching oh and by the way
there is now a new membership option for
my channel so if you wish to support me
making content like this please consider
becoming a member by pressing the join
button next to the Subscribe button and
I'll be seeing you next time